hey where is it dropped by the view
today and things got a little
contentious when the conversation turned
to Julian Assange
so of course Pamela is a good friend of
the WikiLeaks founder who is now in jail
charged with violating the Espionage Act
he's an interesting guy I mean he's
obviously ruffled the feathers of some
very powerful people and powerful people
wants to bring it when you were at him
he was allegedly kicked out of the
Ecuadorian Embassy because he was
defecating everywhere and creating men
oh that's a snack and they came in it's
not true there was video of things that
happened I mean what would you do if
you're locked in a room for just really
quick Sears well I wouldn't be a cyber
terrorist which he is he lacked
information he did weeks included
classified documents that put our
national security at risk our military
you know who the last guy is lomatin
military how many people have the
military you know government killed
innocently and how many has WikiLeaks so
you think the military is putting a calm
down sir I'm actually genuinely a relay
should be we have war crimes need to be
punished and they haven't the the war
crimes that he's exposed
no one's no one's done anything about it
but they put him in jail to shut him up
Sarge interfered another 2016 election
by conspiring with Russia to by
releasing hacked emails hacked emails
which hurt Hillary Clinton it's almost
like is he responsible for giving us
Trump I mean his timing the timing but
you know the Hillary Clinton is
responsible for Trump she was the one
that she would you know know why people
think of you I would he helped Trump
well he wasn't helping Trump he was
trying to tell the American people true
information that Hillary Clinton was
doing so make an educated choice when I
think FBI kind of put the nail in that
coffin but do you mean to tell me that
he had nothing on Trump come on and that
didn't get released I don't know I don't
know if he has something I'm trying he
would have put it out there blow Italy
stirred up a lot cyber terrorists all
right stand by this it's ridiculous
honey I'm getting hot flashes just
watching it she's gonna hear from all
angles I mean this is we should be
[ __ ] with this situation before it
it's one just on that friend
ship level with her in June it's just
such an odd relationship I don't really
understand their relationship completely
and okay I will say about like the
WikiLeaks I mean it's whole can worms
you can open up in terms of yeah what
what who did what who had dirt on who
but I think the original potential
WikiLeaks was just to expose the truth
let's say or get things out there and I
think as soon as Julian got involved in
the election and you're gonna put
information out on one candidate I think
that's when he really lost people the
fact that now you're kind of choosing
sides you're not being the man of the
people anymore right you're kind of your
community choosing a sign my thing is
what in the hell was Pamela Edison
promoting they got something eventually
I think it was a show possibly I feel
like she went there I don't know hey you
know what it takes courage
I mean she's Canadian so you know I'm
gonna just try to privately root for her
but to go on there and to speak about
something that is so controversial
especially the view of all places like
they're gonna fight you know and says
horrible hosts in terms of Megan Pamela
was strong even if you don't agree with
her kate says it's like watching Bambi
attacked by hunters a big supporter says
it takes a special person to bring
together Megan and joy that's true
that's negative joy seem to be on the
same page lately Megan's been like just
cutting people off on that show like
people who have an opinion I've noticed
lately she's like okay I don't
okay I'm gonna because that's a worse
for even know like anytime even though
people attack her for it I think that's
what fuels her popularity the way or at
least why people are tuning in because
they want to see her gay contentious
doesn't have to be because sometimes
just seeing interviews where they'll
kind of back off like really going after
someone even though they'll talk about
that person when they're not there but
no Megan was willing to go at
pamellingson really in sort of you know
Pamela's kind of saying oh he's an
interesting guy know like it was my
favorite part of that whole thing was
Pamela
her body was like this right she was
done what I said she's a child said I
joined in her job right I'm mad at
Julianne too